the Joe Rogan experience ever question
for you though what do you cuz like you
know you do talk a lot about like woke
stuff kind of going amok great mm-hmm
doesn't not bother you though about
Bernie that he aligns himself with some
characters who are super woke up
anything woke activist in particular
yeah well I mean he also aligns himself
with people at Cornel West who was
brilliant and has some amazing ideas
about that and it like looks at it from
a an accurate and educated perspective I
think a lot of the the woke Ness is a
sign of a cultural shift in the right
direction
less racism less homophobia less
fill-in-the-blank all those all the
things that we that trouble us about
like evil behavior and even greed
corporate greed all these these things
that trouble us about the influence that
money has on politics and Bernie clearly
stands against all that stuff and I
think that when you see these the this
woke stuff you know it goes amuck
you have to look at it on a spectrum
it's like the crazy antifa people who
demand 100% compliance with woek
ideology or they'll hit you in the head
with a bike lock versus people who want
single mothers to be able to have free
education and free health care and give
them the economic support that they have
to raise their family and hopefully give
their children a chance at achieving a
successful comfortable life in this
world versus suppress them versus keep
them in this [ __ ] up system that just
throws them in the meat grinder with
everybody else treat this country like a
community like try to do our best to
help the people that are in a
disenfranchised position because there's
so many try to do our best to in some
way economically uplift all these deeply
impoverished sections of our country
that's those are the good aspects of
woek ideology see all woke ideology
isn't just the you need 78 different
gender pronouns and you know if two
was actually fringe probably it is
fringe but it's also fringe right I mean
like it's there's nothing wrong with
being conservative fiscally there's
nothing brought wrong with being
conservative in the way you dress or the
way you behave you know it's like when
you go far right then things get ugly
right and it's it's the outside edges on
both parties of the mess
most people reasonable people if they
could have conversations with folks even
if they disagreed on certain things they
find themselves somewhere in a
comfortable a comfortable discussion
where you could at least sort through
the ideas and try to figure out why you
think the way you think and why I think
the way I think why how we disagree and
are you right or am I am I wrong like I
want to know you know and and most
people don't these kind of conversations
like trying to figure out if the person
who opposes your philosophy or your
perspective is writing you're wrong
it's very uncomfortable for people right
so what do they do they just [ __ ]
[ __ ] on anybody who's on the other side
and they don't talk to when there's a
very little exchange of ideas in between
the right and the left one of the guys I
really like talking to is Dan Crenshaw
who is a right wing guy it's very
reasonable very reasonable he's so much
respect for doing that thing on SNL -
yes yes that was great I mean oh it was
such a nice meal Cooper like to see yes
we and it's so rare nowadays like this
you know dividing line between Ryan 11
and things are just so so hyper hyper
polarize so yeah I mean you can't like
guys will go on a fox news show and
people scream at them you know why how
dare you use that Blake Jimmy Dore just
did Tucker Carlson show and people would
just [ __ ] all over the place for doing
then using his platform and what of
course he's using his platform he's
getting good ideas out there who Tucker
Jimmy door Jimmy door is an amazing
YouTube
I'm sure it's [ __ ] amazing and the
way he breaks down things it's hilarious
but also funny accurate and from the far
left to what yeah I mean I I disagree
with him a lot politically but like he's
he actually entertains me yeah
he's an angry far-left guy who's funny
and he laughs like wasn't mutts either
that got the dog that has the asthma
laughs oh yeah exactly
I like people crazy laughs because
they're laughs with makes me laugh just
watch for that purpose alone we need
more discussions you know we need more
people that get in and the thing is if
you like people gotten mad at me for
having people on the podcast that are
far-right people particularly in the far
past like many years ago and one of the
things that's hilarious is and they said
his show has had this person that person
this person that person all the all the
negatives and you're talking about 1,500
plus episodes and you list like five or
six andrás if that defines the show well
like I said this is the another example
of the political wonder rule like you in
an interview like one far-right person
so you the whole ignore Jimmy Dore
ignored that you have had a B Martin
Edward Snowden all these people are like
you've done this far right person your
whole show is why right there for Rogan
is a you know well it's easy to cuz I
look like one like I look like I should
be an all right person why cuz you work
out yeah yeah I'm a bald Cagefighting
commentator you know that you know what
that that's a terrible I don't know why
this correlation has really started to
exist but but it has I saw I saw an
article I think was I'm like Guardian
that said something like if you exercise
too much your there was an article about
that like exercise is kind of like a
mask like again they're lumping off
concept yeah they're lumping all these
concepts together articles written by
weak [ __ ] just taking the fire sorry no
yeah it's it's silly there's a lot of
like really brilliant people exercise
all the time right they just enjoy it
they enjoy having a body that works
really well there's a lot of brilliant
people who like racing cars too right
there you know they just enjoy the
mechanical aspect of racing a car it's
kind of the same thing when you do you
do something to your body to juice your
body up to make it stronger and faster
and work better it doesn't mean you're
dumb you're toxic masculine but this
stuff is insidious because it's bad
enough to be in political silos we're
now in cultural silos
they're mapping on each other right so
one of the things that happened when I
first moved here was that you know so
high cuz I didn't grow up here I I
wasn't I didn't know what I shouldn't
like so people would say like oh you
you're Boston like you know educated
liberal coastal elite right but then I
was like I love WWE and so like that's
all people like you know I'm surprised
you watch WWE and I you know this is the
time of like Hardy Boys and Lita I grew
up with that stuff so people will be
surprised and and they will push back on
it and it's it's it's increasingly
become that way like from a person's
consumption habits what they like yeah
hobbies you're now able to map what what
politics they will have or likely to
happen that's dangerous like we
shouldn't be we shouldn't be going down
this road it's been very comforting for
me to see how many left-wing intelligent
well-read educated people actually enjoy
watching the UFC
so talked to so many of them like you're
a fan like oh right and then they want
to have these conversations with me
about fights and about this matchup and
that matchup mark oh wow this is really
interesting like people that you would
never have associated with being like a
fan of like Robert Downey jr. UFC Fan
and we're talking about Wow
Matt Damon UFC Fan yeah any anybody
breaking Mol's really should be elevated
you know like cuz it's alright we just
get more and more entrenched in in these
clusters right and people are scared to
like things like WWE or like anything
they like you know some some people love
the [ __ ] mosh pits
you know what Speaker I like of course
but it's entertaining did you not see
what Vince night meant did like it's
just entertaining
[Applause]